plusieurs années de travail collaboratif
mais aussi plusieurs années d'émotion
c'est une sorte de clap de fin
avec la fin du centenaire de la grande
guerre les archives départementales en
célébrer une nouvelle fois l'histoire à
travers leurs projets collaboratifs
débuter en 2013
une édition qui clôt un peu ce cycle de
commémoration une édition dans la
programmation a été menée conjointement
avec l'ensemble des bénévoles une
édition que l'on voulait avant tout
festive et qui soit une sorte d'hommage
aux contributeurs notamment au travers
de cette exposition photos de portraits
ils sont très actives dans l'ensemble
des projets que l'on mène et sans eux on
pourrait pas arriver à ces résultats les
bénévoles et le public ont voyagé
jusqu'en 1914 en se glissant dans la
peau de poilus du recrutement à l'envoi
de courriers sur le front il y avait une
grosse responsabilité parce que ces
cartes représenté à faire cette
correspondance représente évidemment
beaucoup et puis il fallait aussi bien
entendu dans l'autre sens que les la
correspondance écrite par les familles
puissent parvenir
jusqu'aux premières vit une journée
aussi marquée par des remises de prix
les passionnés pouvait partir en équipe
à la recherche de gueule d'ange dans un
serious game
il ya huit étapes pour pouvoir trouver
finalement qui est gueule d'ange on est
à la recherche d'un personnage qui a
fait des croquis et donc on essaie de
retrouver le nom de ce gueule d'ange je
suis une adepte des archives
départementales dont déjà moi je légers
connaît déjà depuis très longtemps donc
c'était une évidence de fer en fait ce
jeu depuis 2013 plus de 7000 personnes
ont été touchées par l'ensemble des
projets menés par les archives
départementales